-Guys, we have exactly
four shows left
before we go on Christmas break,
which means it's time for
that beloved "Tonight Show"
tradition.
It's time for "12 Days of
Christmas Sweaters."
Here we go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪ 12 days of
Christmas sweaters ♪
♪ Four days left ♪
-That's right.
Every show between now and
Christmas, we'll be giving
one lucky audience member
a phenomenal Christmas sweater
from the "Countdown to
Christmas" cabinet.
Now...
[ Cheers and applause ]
Since there are
four shows left --
wow -- let's open door
number four.
[ Drum roll ]
Ooh, that's right in the middle.
Go for it, bud,
whenever you're ready.
Ah! Very nice.
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
Beautiful.
Oh!
Wow. It lights up.
Can we dim the lights
a little bit?
I thought it lit up.
Oh, it lights up when you move?
[ Cheers and applause ]
I don't know what -- Wow.
Oh, yeah.
Alright. Alright.
Wow. It just kind of blinks
when it wants to blink.
Alright, here we go.
Let's see who's going home with
tonight's sweater, okay?
Everyone look at
your seat number.
If I call your number,
come on down.
Quest, can I get a drum roll,
please?
[ Drum roll ]
Seat number 4-3-3!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Yo!
Hey!
Welcome, welcome, welcome.
Wow.
Oh, my gosh.
This is going to be more
like a dress for you.
[ Laughter ]
What is your name?
-I'm Jessica.
-Jessica, where are you from,
Jessica?
-Colombia.
-Colombia, oh, my goodness!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Jessica, welcome to the show.
-Thank you.
-Thank you for being here.
Do you have anything like this
at home?
-No.
-Oh, my gosh.
Well, would you like to
try it on right now?
-Well, I feel so happy
to be here,
especially for this present.
I was talking with a guy before.
[ Laughter ]
They know.
-Is everything okay?
-The cold weather is crazy
for me here
because in my country it is
warm, so this is perfect.
-Try it on.
I think it'll look great on you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah. Oh, yeah. Look at this.
There's no wrong way
to wear it.
Oh, my good-- Look at this!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Look at that! Come on now!
Yes!
Oh, it's so beautiful.
Congratulations.
It'll keep you warm.
Welcome. Thank you for being
here. I appreciate it.
One more time for our audience
member right there.
Stick around.
[ Cheers and applause ]
When we come back,
we're singing
a special Christmas song
with Matthew McConaughey!
Come on back!
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]